Wow welcome to our last day in Venice
today we're going to be doing a snapchat
challenge it was kind of crazy Jenna was
like whoa look at this citizen app chat
challenge as one of the filters so we're
gonna try to do it the here's our
challenges first up on our snapchat
completion list is dancing st. marks
it's got to be empty but that beyond
impossible because we definitely slept
in today so get this place empty not
going to happen
get out we completed the test is it
almost half a challenge it's basically a
personal challenge we wanted to get a
copy chief Agartha got it we're on the
gondola ride you guys when we went to
Vegas and rode the Venice canals there
now we're here in Venice actually riding
the gondola this completes two tasks for
us I got to give Jenna a smooch and I
asked for directions to checked off the
snapchat list we do a gondola ride okay
great right here all right
I asked direction
gondola ride direction smooch snapchat
challenge almost complete now we need
pizza oh no what do we how do we get
better call a date Pizza guys that
completes our snapchat challenge I'm
pretty excited about it
that was the first-ever snapchat
challenge that ever saw in the fact it
was over years as a euro snapchat I
don't know why or are there more of
those if you guys got those for your ass
I'm not sure kind of cool I completed it
as well you can see it on my channel
it's me Jenny Jenna probably posted a
few days before me but whatever we're
gonna now head back to the hotels check
out the rooftop bar and then I'm heading
off to Ibiza I'm going to Croatia to see
my roots okay cool so have a say bye bye
see ain't no kamae in Germany those are
definitely knockoff Apple watches kind
of incredible Airport
I'll see you in Germany I think I don't
know somewhere you somewhere okay bye
see ya have fun enjoy a chef I took a
pill in Ibiza to show Johnny there like
that was I would never I would never
absent last p.m. in your magnesium you
bye
alright so made it to Ibiza and now I'm
going over to see Martin garrix show
with this first one here in the visa of
the summer
what's a visa
see you guys so much for coming tonight
hey guys let's go crazy make some
Oh
everybody jumped
somebody has a drone and I'm so jealous
it's the Phantom 4 - oh I'm so jealous I
was going to try to bring it but I
didn't have enough room yeah I gotta get
out of here
so really cool place called Caliph of
Allah the water is so beautiful and so
clear and then we also went into like
this little cave area where you could
take pictures and video but we drove in
on one of these little boat things I've
actually never seen these before but
they seem to be like all over the
islands and people are just kind of like
cruising around on them now we're at
vessel beach already it's lunch everyone
thinks logging is weird and they don't
know what I'm doing
that's like you don't need shoes and
really yeah it displaced physically on
the beach I just say I'm reading the
water is so clear especially if they
kind of your advise it to make it super
clear I'm thinking that's this stuff
that's all over the beach
he recognizes when somebody likes dogs
you want to be on YouTube no tell us
about your boat cuz we had so much fun
today
not typical is it big boat handsome
captain good gin and tonics
so I had such an awesome time in Europe
and all kinds of crazy destinations
that's the end of this video and I think
the euro trip actually that's not true
because I'm going to meet Jenna in
Munich and then we're heading back to
Pittsburgh so there'll be some
Pittsburgh vlogs and you get to see
Maddie and all kinds of great Maddie
videos because he's at home with my
parents so see you guys later bye
on this little shuttle boat not a bus
it's a boat because we are indeed in
Venice and basically the only way to get
around here is by